the release of the operation
yellowhammer documents along with a
Scottish Court ruling that the
suspension of Parliament was unlawful
have intensified calls for MPs to return
to Westminster amid accusations of
authoritarianism dictatorship and a
contempt for the rule of law Boris
Johnson's critics are wrong though to
accuse him about rage ously trying to
subvert democracy by threatening to
ignore Parliament's decision to prolong
our stay in the EU actually he's
fighting to save democracy the 21 Tory
MP expelled from the Tory party they all
oppose brexit which is the party's most
central policy and if the Tories win an
election with a majority or not they'd
be back in the Commons continuing their
civil war by taking no deal off the
table there remain no Parliament is
tying the Prime Minister's hands in the
way the Labour foreign secretary Ernest
Bevin memorably said we're sending him
naked to the conference chamber most
horror MPs I talked to are sticking with
Boris and the machismo talk because they
calculate the threat to democracy if the
referendum result is not delivered
outweighs arguments about whether the PM
can or can't get around to comments
votes which were designed with one
purpose to kill brexit just a couple
questions so is a No Deal brexit the
will of the people the will of the
people Fermi was expressed in the
biggest democratic vote well I can
answer the question my way the the will
of the people was for Britain to leave
the European Union the seventeen point
four million people who voted for that
sent a very clear instruction to
Parliament Parliament gets its
sovereignty not from those self-serving
MPs from the people who put them there
and the map the mandate was very clear
take us out of the European Union there
was nothing on the ballot paper about
Deal or No Deal about misses with mrs.
maids withdrawal - it was to get us out
and we should have gone out a mark 213
first so you think we're in the will of
people to leave with the deal we just
negotiated through the trees mates but
then we should leave the European Union
and I tell you what I would have done
last time I would have voted for her
deal worse not a great deal but better
than what we've got at the moment that
the antics of your side the remainders
that paralyzing Parliament they're
paralyzing the country and because of
because of that confidence
is draining away from businesses who are
crying out for a decision so neither
fryer says that that's the were still in
history says it's worse than staying in
the EU s as most breakfast they say it's
worse than saying in the UK means we're
less sovereign following the rules of
the EU with no say-so objectively that
is the version of brexit that most
precious waters do not want would you
not agree I I think most brexit voters
don't want that but I tell you this
they're so fed up now I mean they just
want to get out and I would support No
Deal breaks it if that's always like I
can't believe you're not I can't believe
you're not actually we were utterly
wedded to stopping brexit in its tracks
I don't know why you from your lure a
lot well it is like that it's like that
need to protect democracy yes by the way
I didn't vote brexit but I've always
said I think protecting a democracy is
of the utmost importance which is why I
think a lot of remain errs except that a
deal is something that we need to pursue
right how do you protect democracy by
having the executives say they might be
willing to break the law which Boris
Johnson did by misleading the Queen and
Prague in Parliament illegally which the
highest on the matter so far Trane's
found that this probation is unlawful
which means that the third thing that's
now happened is that a legislature which
is one of the constitutional branches of
state that is crucial to our democracy
fundamental to our democracy is
suspended potentially to stop - so you
doing you choose the verdicts of the
appeal court in Scotland you ignore the
first ignore and you ignore the verdict
of the High Court in England and Wales
which said there was nothing improper or
illegal now except to the Supreme Court
decide but what I would say the highest
court that has decided on the matter
yeah has found that our Parliament if
currently unlawfully yeah yeah that is
so serious and can I just say put this
in perspective for many of this we
talked about broking if parent hadn't
been proud it we'd have met for a
further four days and then next week
these MPs who were crying blue murder
constitutional vandalism constitutional
average they'll go off to their party
the Lib Dems Joe Swenson she'll be there
in Bournemouth by the sea or and then
we'll go to the ladies Brighton they
want to sit and not do they I've not
heard a single member of the Labour
Shadow Cabinet say will cancel the party
conference because they let you hear
from joanna cherry who is the SNP
politician who brought this case this is
a unanimous decision a unanimous
decision by Scotland's highest courts
that the prorogation of parliament by
Boris Johnson was unlawful and as Tommy
Shepherd one of my folk petitioners has
pointed out now for every moment
Parliament remains prorogued the British
government are breaking the law so we as
politicians are calling for Parliament's
to be recalled performance utilising
what this government is up to in the
nation directly now we've had we've
heard how this government has so far
been said it's willing to break the law
has now suspended the legislature the
third way in which they have not
protected democracy is that we've now
heard a cabinet minister suggesting that
it might be valid to regard the
judiciary as biased I cannot think of a
more serious attack on our democracy in
my lifetime and if that's your idea of
protecting it I think that we're living
on completely different planets you're
living respectfully I know I don't mean
this personally but there is if anyone's
living on another planet it's those who
have completely lost touch with what
people outside of Westminster and I know
Scotland's outside of business the vast
majority of people who voted for brexit
they are sickened by the fact that it
would appear unless you're a Scottish
judge or you studied PPE at Oxford you
don't have the wit you don't have the
Internet
you're not even to be listened to the
fact that these as he and rude rightly
says these appalling MPs decide to
perform in this fashion they were given
a task to carry out Boris Johnson come
back let's remember Andrews debaters an
Apple Boris Johnson had absolutely no
alternative those 21 who voted that way
I hope that they find a way back in but
this has to be done for the actually for
the mental health of everybody not just
somebody who contacted you let's just
hear from Boris Johnson there's a
massive massive agenda we need a Queen's
speech
that's why Parliament is in recess now
because you always have a recess before
a Queen's speech and anybody who says
it's all this stuff about it being
anti-democratic I mean
don't even work break what a load of
nonsense we we were very very clear that
if people wanted a democratic moment if
they wanted an election we offered it to
the neighbor opposition and mysteriously
they decided not to go for it
so you mentioned to me before that you
think I might have disagreed with
something I tweeted in 2016 if you'd
have gone through my most recent tweets
you would probably have seen that
probably a few months ago I called Boris
Johnson and absolute Wozzeck I thought
he would be the worst Prime Minister in
history probably for our country and I
actually will stand corrected on that
because I have quite a lot of regard and
respect for what Boris Johnson is trying
to do and the way that he is trying to
move things forward because people have
lost trust and faith in our politicians
the way they're behaving we'll come on
to it I'm sure in the next bit as well
they are behaving like absolute childish
idiots often now not not infrequently
often and the situation is and it's all
well and good and you studied EU law and
all of these technicalities and all the
rest of it when you ask most people who
voted brexit why they're frustrated and
I speak you know I speak to people often
about this and I represent my own view
here too on our leave for though
everyone received it said Parliament
will implement whatever you've earned
and it is that simple point which is
frustrating people and Boris Johnson
seems to be the only person who has the
balls to stand up say what he believes
and try to move things forward
okay it's now time for me to probe that
debate